wir bleiben einmal beim Russland Problem
weil da Frau Hermenau plädieren sie ja
eigentlich für etwas Pragmatismus ja
unbedingt also ich habe nicht verstanden
warum wir keine Außenministerin mehr
haben aber eine kriegsministerin die
ständig davon spricht dass man den Putin
vernichten muss als ob der da alleine
Stunde das ist die ganze normenklatura
und da gab es auch immer ein Teil der
sagte lass uns nach Asien gehen die
Europäer haben einander Waffel also das
muss man glaube ich mal so festhalten
das wird nur landläufig nicht erwähnt
das darf keiner sagen ich komme bestimmt
morgen auch wieder auf dem Twitter Index
aber egal der Punkt auf den ich
hinausführt ist eigentlich folgender wir
haben uns glaube ich in der Frage
verrannt weil wir natürlich auch gerne
festhalten wollen an unserer Vorstellung
aus dem letzten Jahrhundert von einer
liberalen Welt und diese liberale Welt
die ist schön eine grüne Wiese mit
Blumen alles super die die Hummeln und
die bienenbrummen alles super aber der
Punkt an der Sache ist das ganz woanders
dieser Reichtum hergestellt wird wir
haben das immer ausgeblendet wir sind
erstens auf den Export angewiesen fast
50% unserer staatlichen Einnahmen es
kommen über Exporte und angegliederte
Dienstleistungen die Autobranche haben
wir ruiniert die ist Angst weg die ist
gar nicht mehr da das Bisschen was noch
da ist möchte E-Mobility machen bei den
Strompreisentwicklung die ist skizziert
habe können Sie das der Pfeife rauchen
Milliarden Gewinne gemacht
alles sehen die Entlassungen Ingolstadt
am stattgefunden also sie wollen dass
wir mit Putin reden um ihre These
zusammenzufassen wahrscheinlich gar
nicht mehr können weil wir gar nicht
mehr die Power dafür haben also wir
waren immer schon so ein bisschen der
Affenfelsen auf Gibraltar als Europäer
so auch für die Amerikaner die fanden
das immer alles sehr unübersichtlich
werde hat er eigentlich was zu sagen die
deutschen den wurde jetzt eingeflüstert
Mensch dann mach doch hier einfach
Situation und macht von Frau bärbock
dass sie also schon reichen wenn sie
diplomatischer sprechen ich habe gar
keine großen Forderungen ich möchte
einfach nur nicht dass immer gleich von
Vernichtung und total im Krieg
gesprochen wird das finde ich wirklich
unangemessen und ich würde mir wünschen
dass wir irgendwie so eine Schiene
finden mit den Russen zu verhandeln die
haben jetzt im jamalfeld schon
angefangen
Olaf Scholz
in vielen Fragen nicht unterstützt meine
eure Frage hat der versagt in meinen
Augen aber in der Frage unterstütze ich
ihn weil es gefährlich ist die Russen
werden da sein immer auch noch in den
nächsten 10 und 20 Tagen
die Amerikaner sind die Ansprechpartner
der Russen das waren sie immer wir
kriegen einen neuen Kalten Krieg wir
kriegen eine Ost und eine Westwelt und
die ostwelt wird irgendwo in der Ukraine
oder am Rand der Ukraine dann ihre
Grenze ziehen und so runtergehen wir
kriegen aber dann in der ostwelt ein
rohstoffkartell Europa ist nichts ohne
Rohstoff und Energie das merken
also eine Frage habe ich schon also ich
verstehe grundsätzlich dass sie
Diplomatie fordern die Frage ist nur wir
haben uns ja nun selbst durch unsere
falschen Energiepolitik in eine Lage
reinmiert in der wenn ich Putin wäre
auch kein Grund sehe derzeit stehen
die ganzen Forderungen auch viele
deutsche Gewerbetreibende die ich ja
menschlich nachvollziehen kann macht
Nord Stream 2 aus sind ja völlig
realitätsfremd weil dadurch auch wenn
wir es aufmachen wollten kein russisches
gasfließen das stimmt nicht
ich würde gerne mal testen aber
den Test politisch zu bezahlen also das
Risiko wird momentan
Lösung sprechen also Frau Hermann hat
ihre Lösung angeboten was ihre Lösung
wie soll es aussehen nee Waffenlieferung
wirtschaftssektion noch was wollen sie
das Thema Ukraine ja schon mehrfach und
ich glaube dass am Ende der kriegt
militärisch entschieden wird dass die
Sanktionen in der Tat ähm die westliche
Welt mindestens wenn ich härter treffen
als die Russen und dass die Russen noch
eine Weile in der Lage sind das
durchzuhalten auch weil sie ihre eigene
Bevölkerung alles zumuten werden das
muss man auch sagen die Russen haben
überhaupt keine Achtung vor dem
Individuum so wie sie ihre Soldaten vor
die ukrainischen Kanonen schicken als
Kanonenfutter und sie dort ja letztlich
in ihr Unglück rennen lassen wenn sie
auch bereit ihre eigenen Leute zu opfern
insofern da muss man sich gar keine
Illusionen machen die Russen haben damit
ihre eigenen Leuten keine Gnade ich sehe
ist halt nicht das ist ein Fenster für
Verhandlungen gibt weil Putin sich keine
Niederlage leisten kann er ist als
Mensch psychologisch so aufgerichtet
dass er nicht verliert über Putin reden
wollen wir einmal reinhören was er
selber gesagt hat um auf dem aktuellen
Stand zu sein
ich möchte diejenigen die solche
Äußerungen über Russland machen daran
erinnern dass auch unser Land über
verschiedene zerstörungsmittel verfügt
und in einigen Fällen sind sie moderner
als die der NATO-Länder dies ist kein
Bluff und diejenigen die versuchen uns
mit Atomwaffen zu erpressen sollten
wissen dass sich die Wetterfahne drehen
und auf sie zeigen kann
Klaus wie ernst muss man diese Warnung
nehmen vom Putin na ja ernster als mir
das jetzt im Moment innerhalb der
westlichen Staatengemeinschaft so
vorkommt jedenfalls in der
veröffentlichten Meinung ich finde und
zwar nicht weil er möglicherweise jetzt
zu einer großen Gegend Offensive mit
ganz vielen Panzern die dann irgendwie
im Schnee stecken bleiben oder sowas
ausholt sondern weil er ich folge dem
Gedanken von VP3 ein Mann ist der nicht
verlieren kann und ein Mann der nicht
verlieren wird und ein Mann der für sich
entscheidet wenn ich schon verliere und
untergehen nämlich noch ganz viele mit
wahrscheinlich das ist die Mentalität
und das macht mir heute schon Gänsehaut
ich glaube auch dass so eine
gänsehautwelle heute ein bisschen durch
Deutschland gegangen ist angesichts der
atomdrohung er ist ja nicht so dass der
jetzt da irgendwie Nebenraum geht und so
macht und dann ist Deutschland weg aber
die die die die Sorge dass er als
zurückgedrängt da zu etwas seine
Verzweiflungstat das ist glaube ich das
Wort greifen könnte die kann ich nicht
ganz ignorieren und gefolgt für mich
aber eine andere Logik als bei ihnen aus
bei mir folgt und auch aus bei ihnen
weil sie haben die ganze Zeit gesagt
Putin hat wahrscheinlich kein Interesse
an Verhandlungen ich bin nicht sicher ob
der Westen Interesse an Verhandlungen
mit Wladimir Putin haben sollte ich
glaube er kann nur in die Knie gezwungen
werden mit militärischer Kraft Olaf
Scholz hat heute noch mal daran erinnert
dass wir auf der Seite des Rechts stehen
und nicht auf der Seite der Gewalt dann
muss man aber Olaf Scholz dran erinnern
dass man manchmal Gewalt braucht um
Recht durchzusetzen und genau in diesem
Moment befinden wir uns jetzt und
Wirtschaftssanktionen der beispielsweise
bislang nicht erfolgreich also Gabor
Steingart beispielsweise der Bevölkerung
ins Kino
als Ansicht ich würde sagen das die
wirtschaftsaktionen in Russland
natürlich wirken aber sie machen nicht
sie haben nicht so viel impact nicht so
viel Auswirkung wegen der Mentalität die
gerade beschrieben worden ist also die
Leidensfähigkeit der Russen ist
natürlich viel viel größer als die
Leidensfähigkeit der deutschen die schon
quietschen wenn Sie die Heizung drunter
drehen müssen ja ich mache es jetzt mal
bewusst polemisch gegen uns selbst aber
ich glaube dass es Momente gibt da gilt
das diplomatische Gebot dass man immer
im Gespräch bleiben können muss nicht
doch und ich glaube dann das ist meine
ich ja da habe ich eine andere ich
glaube das dass das mit dem Menschen
Wladimir Putin mit dem Präsidenten nicht
funktionieren wird und deshalb gibt es
nur die Möglichkeit in niederzuringen
alles und am Ende vor Gericht zu stellen
wenn er dann noch am Leben alles andere
würde ja alles andere würde ja auch
bedeuten wenn wir uns in meiner
Weltpolitik umschauen das große Nationen
immer kleinere überfallen können und
dann gibt es den Ruf nach Diplomatie
weil man sagt na ja wir können die eh
nicht bezwingen oder die werden dann
durchdrehen ehrlich
[Gelächter]
guten Gründen irgendwann nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg etabliert dass alle
Staaten gleiche Rechte haben sollen und
das ist nicht ein Rechte stärkeren gibt
sondern eine Stärke des Rechts und wir
haben ja noch andere Fälle ich nenne nur
China und Taiwan die gucken ganz genau
hin die Chinesen was da passiert und
wenn die den Eindruck haben die
Weltgemeinschaft akzeptiert das was die
Russen da machen dann werden die sich
Taiwan holen und deswegen müssen wir
alles dafür tun damit ein Diktator wie
Putin gestoppt werden
keine Muckis und das ist Moment die
Tatsachen die Russen fahren nur mit
Amerikanern und ihre Amerikaner haben
kein Interesse jetzt mal schnell zu
verhandeln das Problem bleibt in Europa
liegen wir Europäer sind aber diejenigen
auf dem Schulhof die sonst immer dran
sind bei der klassenkeile und jetzt
kriegen wir sie mal richtig weil wir
nämlich immer die Backen aufblasen weil
wir immer großer Werte vorantragen wie
eine Monstranz bei der Prozession aber
Demokratie
sind mit Gewalt das durchzusetzen was
wir für richtig halten
die Frage ist definitiv wie groß ist
denn die Angst jetzt vom Atomkrieg also
ich finde wir sind jetzt schon sehr
schnell wieder okay für mich wirklich
sehr beängstigend worden weggerückt muss
man wie ernst muss man denn also man
muss das ernst nehmen vielleicht gibt es
irgendeinen Szenario von dem
probeatomschlag irgendwo in der Ostsee
ich weiß das nicht ich habe keine Ahnung
aber was ich sehe ist wenn sie mal die
Live Karte aufrufen Google wo die
Kriegsschiffe alle sind die die Welt so
hat da sind die meisten von europäischen
Küsten in der Nordsee in der Ostsee es
ist ziemlich eindeutig und das heißt man
rechnet auch damit dass es eskaliert
jetzt sage ich mal einen Punkt wenn es
wirklich dazu kommen sollte was ich
immer noch nicht glaube ist ja waren die
Russen immer vorsichtig die einzigen die
hier Atome auf dem eingesetzt haben
waren die Amerikaner aber wenn es
wirklich dazu kommen sollte dann ist
Deutschland das Zentrum der
Auseinandersetzung nicht die Ukraine
dann sind wir dran und das waren
Geschichte
man wird ein Diktator man wird ein
Diktator wie Putin nicht Stopp mit dem
man sagt man weich zurück oder wenn ein
Land angreift dann redet man von
Diplomatie sondern man muss eine eigene
Stärke aufbauen ich ähm Sachen es gibt
einen Ausgleich der Interessen und wer
das nicht mehr beherrscht und Kissen hat
da deutlich gesagt die Amerikaner werden
nicht kommen und Soldaten nach Europa
schicken ihr müsst das selber hinkriegen
wenn wir aber nicht die Kapazitäten
haben militärisch von denen man ausgehen
müsste um das zu schaffen da muss man
sich genau überlegen wieder
Interessensausgleich aussieht die Russen
werden am 15 September gesehen die
Russen werden mit Iran China Indien den
arabischen Ländern im Persischen Golf
Saudi-Arabien wahrscheinlich noch mit
Brasilien mal sehen wie die Wahl ausgeht
jetzt in Brasilien einen rohstoffkartell
bilden da ist Europa aber ganz blöd dran
weil nämlich die Energie und die
Rohstoffe Dinge sind die wir zwingend
brauchen um überhaupt noch in der Lage
zu sein exportfähig zu sein ich habe ihn
vorhin geschildert die Exportfähigkeit
manifestiert ungefähr 50% unserer
Ausgaben als Staat auch im Sozialbereich
überall wenn das aber nicht mehr
erwirtschaftet werden kann aus diesen
genannten Gründen dann haben wir ja so
was von einem Bürgerkrieg an der Hacke
in Europa das wird dramatisch dann muss
man einfach mal zu Ende denken und
überlegen können wir das Stemmen einfach
nur wie junge Leute voranbrechen auch
super ähnlich aber ich finde
jetzt
die Europäer und die Amerikaner zusammen
schön großen hinsetzen und gucken ob sie
die Sache wenn das so das klingt ja so
als ob man nur mal reden müsste und dann
wäre alles gut also wirklich etwas naiv
und einfach das glaube ich nicht also 58
naiv bin sondern die Frage ist ob ich
meinen Sohn den Krieg schicken
vielleicht können wir noch mal ganz kurz
also ich muss mal sagen aber ist auf
jeden Fall nicht so viel kann man sagen
danke schön für die anderen
zurück zu der zu der Angst weil ich
glaube dass Angst um etwas sehr diffuses
ist was am Ende bei der
Entscheidungsfindung nicht hilft sondern
genau genommen lähmt und obwohl ich die
Angst grundsätzlich ja nachvollziehen
kann ich erlebe sie im eigenen
Familienkreis ich habe heute eine Stunde
bei der Mutter diskutiert die ist 82
bald und die kann sich an den Zweiten
Weltkrieg noch aus eigener Erinnerung
erinnern und sie hört die bombenschläge
aus Dresden weil sie nicht weiter von
entfernt gewohnt hat insofern die Angst
muss man total ernst nehmen aber man
muss auch schauen wie realistisch ist
das und ich wir haben alle ein bisschen
geschmunzelt weil Putin Satz vorhin das
ist kein Bluff also da kann man
natürlich so oder so darüber denken
tatsächlich glaube ich dass es relativ
unwahrscheinlich ist wenn sie mich jetzt
naiv damit kann ich leben ich halte es
für relativ unwahrscheinlich das Putin
das tun wird und ich glaube dass die
Antwort der Amerikaner bei aller Kritik
die man sonst an ihnen haben kann
richtig was zu sagen sollten die Russen
das tun
nutzen amerikanische Antwort geben das
will keiner von uns da sind wir uns
glaube ich alle einig aber das was schon
viel zu lange passiert ist in diesem
Konflikt war dass bei den Europäern
gerade bei uns Deutschen nicht ganz klar
war wo wir lange Zeit gestanden haben
bemerken sie Kriegslust da sind sie
jetzt anderer Mann aber Frau Hermenau
kriegsministerin hat seine
Außenministerin würden sie damit also
ich hatte Frau bärbox für nicht sehr
mutig und das heißt diplomatisch
formuliert sie äußerten immer nur dann
Kritik wenn sie im Windschatten anderer
tun kann als Nancy Pelosi nach Taiwan
gereist ist war persönlich wünschen dass
Frau diplomatisch ich halte die ich
halte sie für nicht besonders fähig für
das Amt dass sie bekleidet und so wie
sie jetzt nicht den Mund aufmacht um
Iran die Frauenrechte zu verteidigen
macht den anderen Stellen auch nicht die
Mund auf und es ist ziemlich billig die
Rosen zu kritisieren wenn
die blicken und die Dellen und die
Amerikaner letztlich den Krieg für uns
dort führen wenn man die wenigen Waffen
rausnimmt die Deutschland dann doch
liefert also ich halte Frau bärbock an
der Stelle für nicht wirklich
zielführend und ich glaube nicht dass es
wenn sie sich mit la Prof trifft weil da
hat Frau Hermann auch völlig recht wir
sind gar kein Gesprächspartner für die
Russen den nimmt sie doch zu Recht nicht
ernst das heißt es verhandeln nur die
Großmächte am Ende auf Augenhöhe also
müsste beiden Händen
ich glaube dass militärisch schon eine
ganze Menge passieren muss und dann
müssen die westeuropäischen Kräfte und
die Amerikaner zusammenhalten dieser
Konflikt wird dass es meine persönliche
Meinung militärisch entschieden und wenn
die Russen in eine Lage kommen in der
sie am Ende wirklich verhandeln müssen
denn wenn sie es tun insofern ergänze
ich die Amerikaner haben sicherlich kein
Interesse aber die Russen haben sich
derzeit auch nicht
Russland darf nur auf keinen Fall
gewinnen Russland muss diesen Krieg
verlieren weil wir haben ja wir haben
eben wir haben genau wir haben wir haben
was wir was wir was mir wirklich jetzt
hier fehlt in der Diskussion da finden
wirklich ja schlimmste Verbrechen statt
Vergewaltigung der Putin attackiert
Krankenhäuser
Zivilisten also furchtbare Verbrechen
und da kann man doch nicht einfach
hinsehen und sagen aber was wir
verhandeln diplomatische Lösung da
brauche ich doch eine entschlossene
Antwort allein ein Gewinn dieser was
heißt für sie gewinnen in dem Fall also
aus meiner Sicht muss Putin und müssen
die russischen Truppen komplett aus der
Ukraine raus also das beinhaltet auch
natürlich den Don Bass und beinhaltet
auch die krimputin Nadja 2014 angefangen
mit den ersten Angriffen auf die Ukraine
auf ein souverän Staat und das können
wir das kann der Westen das kann
eigentlich jede Demokratie eigentlich
jeder souveräne Land in der Welt nicht
hinnehmen und da brauchst du eine
entschlossene Antwort und es gibt so
viele schreckliche Ereignisse die dort
stattfinden also da kann man nicht sagen
ja genau aber das das wurde überhaupt
nicht thematisiert und deswegen finde
ich muss es auch eine entschlossene
Antwort geben und wir können doch nicht
sagen wir reden mal so ein bisschen über
Diplomatie
dann würden sie auf die Bundeswehr
hinschicken oder wie weit würden Sie
gehen für den sie genau wir haben jetzt
ja gesagt wir wollen nicht selber
Kriegspartei werden ich halte aber
Waffenlieferung für absolut notwendig
auch dass da die Ampelkoalition viel
mehr macht also Panzer müssen unbedingt
geliefert werden und im Moment geht es
ja sagen ja im Moment im Moment geht's
ja auch in die richtige Richtung also
die Ukraine gewinnt ja Land zurück und
da passiert ja etwas was wir selber
wahrscheinlich vor einigen Monaten gar
nicht gedacht hätten und deswegen der
entschlossene Antwort ich will jetzt
doch die die muss es geben und die kann
es auch geben das zeigt dass
entschlossen handeln von vielen anderen
Ländern also ich glaube dass dieser
Gedanke die gesamte ukrainische das
gesamte ukrainische Gebiet muss auf
jeden Fall von Russland von der
russischen Armee und von Putin befreit
werden ist in gefährlicher Gedanke weil
in diesem gewinnen wollen von Putin
steckt ja auch etwas von einem
nationalen Stolz drin und ich glaube
dass der Sieger das wäre in ihrem
Planspiel ja die Ukraine und der Westen
sehr darauf Acht geben muss dass er den
Verlierer nicht zu sehr demütigt wir
haben da ja selber
historisch zwei Erfahrungen nämlich eine
nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg wo es
geschehen ist und eine nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg wo es sozusagen viel Kritik
geben kann aber doch besser gelaufen ist
und
das bedeutet man muss ja erstmal aber
wenn man einem Diktator entschlossen
man muss ja mit den Menschen die in dem
die sozusagen in den Besiegten Land das
fällt er mir schon schwer bei Russland
überhaupt zu sagen weil man sich nicht
vorstellen kann dass dieser Gigant dass
dieser Gigant überhaupt verlieren kann
aber wir sind in ihrem Denkmuster dann
würde ich dann wieder als Diplomat sehr
darauf achten dass man den nicht der am
Boden liegt auch noch demütigt und
lächerlich macht weil man am Ende muss
man ja mit ihm oder seine Nachfolgern
die übrigens zur gleichen Nation gehören
und zum gleichen Schlager sind sprechen
können und mit gedemütigten zu sprechen
und ihnen etwas aufzuzwingen ist für die
Zeit danach ganz geschweige dass man das
wahrscheinlich mit Russland sowieso
nicht kann irgendwas aufzwingen ist für
die Zeit danach in gefährliches
Denkmuster da würde ich aus unserer
Geschichte lernen